baby Archie kicks off our best royal
moments of 2019
MAGIX it's pretty amazing
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm really happy little Archie
Harrison mountbatten-windsor was born on
May 6th and immediately stole our hearts
because the sweetest temper man who's
really
Megan's mom Doria was part of the photo
op when the Queen and Prince Phillip met
their great-grandson for the first time
I think she has been incredibly
confident as a first-time mother my
understanding is that from everything
from nursing and through what we know is
the fourth trimester has all gone
amazingly well for Megan
two months later the little tyke was
christened at Windsor Castle
uncle William and Auntie Kate were there
but some fans felt William didn't look
all that happy not to be outdone in the
cuteness department Archie's cousin
Louie melted all of our hearts when he
showed off his royal wave during his
very first appearance on the balcony at
Buckingham Palace
keeping it rolling with the Royal kids
Louise big sister Charlotte showed her
sexy side to the paparazzi while
attending a voting event Kate's reaction
priceless nicknamed Claudie the little
princess also started school alongside
with brother George we're pretty sure
she's acing her classes like art math
and science they're treated like any
other child there's no special treatment
for George there won't be any special
treatment for Charlotte either also
cracking our best royal moments Meghan
meeting her long-lost cousin Boston Red
Sox player Mookie Betts in September we
got our best look at baby Archie yet and
it was clear he's a total mini-me of his
dad in South Africa the cute-as-a-button
baby charmed Archbishop Desmond Tutu and
his daughter and what a year of fashion
Kate really stepped up the game with her
gowns and millions of dollars worth of
bling Megan made maternity wear chic and
then wowed us with her post-baby body
wanna look royal our Rachel Smith got to
try on the top that Megan made famous
the husband shirt get a slip into my
husband's shirts all right wait for the
transformation yeah babe
and oh the et got a one-on-one with the
designer Misha nunu who just so happens
to be one of Megan's BFFs so were you in
the Duchess's Essex working alongside
each other the Duchess asked me to
create a shot we had a
conversations about what it should look
like what she was thinking and then she
let me take it from there
listen I love all things Royals Harry
Megan William Kate I'm ride-or-die I
think in a different life you were a
royal I wish the house
[Music]